good okay let's go bones and
okay could be worse let's go pawn again
wouldn't be worse
style yeah
well it's
you know i believe in the beginning of
the last century it would be very smart
it would be called very smart fighting
for the e5 square
okay let's go pawn
and let's go pawn again
and now we go pawn again i think oh dear
well
and pawn again yeah okay
okay
okay let's go palm
[Laughter]
well it's not yet losing here so you
know those pawn moves
still work
no but actually yeah we we might
certainly challenge like make six move
with the night in a row in the opening
or something
okay okay now we go night maybe
so you finally resigned yeah
um
still had like so many bone moves to
play and
well i actually thought i wanted 92 and
then to to prepare g4 sometime but yeah
ah
no this is super okay let's go bishop
maybe
let's go night
okay so now the show is back i guess
let's go pawn
let's go
okay let's go night i see a point
even i don't see my point that's okay
it's good you see it
but i like kelly's stone wall is
strange
okay let's go um
please don't play g4 see c3 is attacked
okay let's go nine
yeah just don't play g4 anything else is
good
uh let's go
i actually don't know
let's actually go pawn check your style
let's sacrifice everything
yeah
over here
you know it's uh
okay the resign button is still uh not
an any other h4 square is near h7
that's all right so once you reach h7
with this pawn we can
you know also resign at once no no once
you research which song
you know it's you know it's called
duplicate
h7 is taken so we should play i mean at
least
look at this yeah
yeah okay let's go knight
oh this is confusing
yeah we could probably keep one piers uh
one piece there
just in case i don't know
i don't need it yeah i really i really
like my phone on g2 i don't want to
sacrifice it anymore
okay let's go pawn
kind of fly like the way we play
yeah
i trained a lot
so this is
okay but now he's surely putting all his
pieces to h7 not yet
um let's maybe go rogue just in case
yeah i don't know why we need it though
but i don't know i'm also not sure what
cases
[Music]
what particular cases
helpful for us
oh dear
um
oh dear
this is actually a little bit strange
maybe rook yeah maybe rook okay let's go
rogue
and see what happens
yeah somehow g5 is inspiring okay you
basically way to move so let's go bishop
let's just prevent
ah prevent is a good tip thank you i
felt like which bishop bishop f1
let's prepare for a new game and so on
no no not yet wow
let's go king now maybe you know i
thought now there is a smart move
just to play bishop back to c1 but okay
okay we go king
oh dear
then we go i think bishop rook and you
know we can still have you know joking
moves
in
in the you know
in the backpack
okay let's go bishop oh sorry sorry yeah
it's also useful okay now what's this
i mean he's doing just the same
okay let's uh
let's probably bring the knight so let's
go night
and night
you know someone on the chat saying i
don't understand this position can
someone give him computer evil so that's
just what we need
oh my god i guess we just ignore it we
go night or something
okay this i didn't find anything like
something but
yeah
and now we dream to go upon again i
believe
okay we go bishop and then we go pawn
what wow this is also decent
okay
okay now we go night yeah
sure
and now we go maybe queen
queen
yeah i don't know
this gives me chills
queen
okay just go bishop and ignore yourself
whatever yeah yeah
is it your last words you know queen
uh now i guess we go something stylish
maybe we'll go pawn simply
yeah i think so
we go paul
probably go king
uh
yeah i don't know maybe we go
like rogue
rick
okay i don't know let's put this one
i can't it's kind of like it actually
okay now we go home
and we go
i don't know what we do here actually
maybe we go rook 404 for the moment
yeah
and now we go i think bishop
and well this is stance okay let's go
pawn and
do something
finally there's only one pawn which can
move let's go pawn again maybe
no
and queen
and maybe rook and you try to confuse
him somehow
i can only confuse myself here but yeah
i'll do my best rule rook again maybe
okay bishop
okay let's try this rook
rook
bishop
rook
yeah
yeah this
it finally worked yeah that's a
masterpiece wow
okay this should be published like okay
i get much or should make a review of
this game for sure